[Music]
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
we'll be discussing Dr Stephen gundry's
diet book The Plant Paradox and we will
answer the question are healthy plant
Foods actually toxic and making you
overweight and sick before we get into
today's video I wanted to quickly tell
you about my sponsor care of so if you
guys have followed any of my Vlogs on my
digestion or my mental health Journey
you probably know that supplements have
been a supportive part of my own
self-care routine I'm a huge proponent
of supplements if they help you achieve
better food Freedom by allowing you to
enjoy the foods you love and I know that
choosing the right supplements has
helped me personally with my sleep
stress digestion and general energy
levels so I was really excited to try it
care of which is a supplement
subscription service that ships high
quality vitamins straight to your door
every month so basically the way it
works is you take this awesome
personalized quiz about your health
goals and it gives you unique
recommendations based on those answers
so for me me my quiz recommended that I
could use vitamin D their protein powder
rhodiola a sleep blend and their gut
check quick sticks for on the go I
really only started using the service
but it really does make it so much
easier to be able to get all of the
supplements that you need in just one
easy place especially because I don't
even have to leave home to get them and
as a dietitian I obviously love that
caref supplements are third party tested
and backed by the latest science which
you guys all know is super important to
me and whenever your goals or your needs
change it's really easy to just update
your quiz and get new recommendations
set in your way so if you're looking to
start a supplement routine or update
your current one take care of quiz to
find out what's recommended for you and
don't forget to use my link in the
description and use my promo code Abby
sharp to get 50 off of your first order
that's pretty amazing and you can pause
the screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with with
current or previous experiences with
disordered eating as always feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are not
already subscribed hit that subscribe
button and follow me over on Tick Tock
and Instagram at Abby's kitchen you can
see I'm in a good mood today because
friends
I'm having my coffee it's Friday when
I'm filming this and I mean the sun is
shining what's not to love well I'll
tell you what's not to love this book so
I get a lot of questions about this
controversial diet book and doctor and I
would say for good reason the tagline of
the plant Paradox the hidden dangers in
healthy foods that cause disease and
weight gain is scary and culty as fat
diets always have this air of conspiracy
to them like they claim to know a secret
that mainstream science is trying to
hide or maybe has missed and this book
is not surprisingly no exception so the
plant Paradox diet and book was written
by cardiologist Dr Stephen gundry who
claims that all of these so-called
healthy plant Foods you've been told to
eat are actually wreaking havoc on your
body and health the culprit a protein
called lectins lectins or killer lectins
as Gendry so affectionately calls them
them are apparently the root cause of
waking and chronic disease he claims
that his protocol will resolve up to 49
different diseases from acne to diabetes
infertility and even cancer finally a
diet that does it all but this
generalized one size fits-all diet isn't
apparently just for your average
relatively healthy Joe he even has an
adjunct program called keto plant
Paradox intensive care designed for
people with diabetes cancer and kidney
failure this is an aside but there are
hugely dangerous implications of
prescribing a generalized fad diet to
people in need of unique Medical
Nutrition Therapy Pharmaceuticals and
comprehensive care but anyway this will
be a huge shocker to you probably but
this diet is riddled with inaccuracies
and contradictions honestly too many to
list but I want to focus in on his
lectin argument because I keep seeing
this pop up in my feeds so first of all
lectins are a group of proteins that can
be found in all plants but are most
abundant in raw legumes like beans
lentils peas soybeans and peanuts and
whole grains like wheat they're known as
phytohemoglutinins which are a class of
protein molecules that bind to
particular carbohydrates like glucose
sucrose and cellulose fiber the effect
that lectins can have on the human body
really does vary and depend on how the
lectin-containing food is prepared and
how much is consumed but the most
dramatic side effect that we've seen is
where people eat raw or undercooked
kidney beans in these rare cases the
lectins have caused red blood cells to
Clump together causing devastating
effects usually though eating them in
excess just causes GI distress like
bloating gas nausea and diarrhea in the
longer term eating raw High lectin Foods
may also interfere with mineral
absorption and because lectins bind to
the lining of the digestive tract they
can affect our good gut bacteria this is
really the Crux of the lectin phobia
Central to gendry's book and this is
where the concept of leaky gut has
really taken off if you haven't heard
the term being thrown around by wellness
influencers and natural health gurus
best you hear it from me first the first
thing you need to know is that leaky gut
is not a legitimate medical diagnosis
rather what they're referring to is
intestinal permeability which can be
affected by a number of factors so the
lining of your intestines are covered in
little finger-like projections known as
microvilli people disappear in the
Finger Lakes and these little fingers
help your gut to absorb important
nutrients and are really like the
gateway to your bloodstream AKA your
nutrient transportation system if the
microvilli or lining gets damaged for
any reason then unwanted substances like
bacteria can pass into your bloodstream
causing all sorts of problems like in
inflammation so we see intestinal
permeability in action in two main ways
firstly under stress conditions like
endurance exercise or pregnancy and
second in patients who suffer from
things like celiacs or Crohn's disease
the difference between the two is that
the leaky gut experienced under stress
conditions can be reversed using dietary
factors like introducing probiotics
whereas diseases like celiacs and
Crohn's it cannot but let's use celiac
disease as an example and just focus on
that because it's linked with a dietary
component of gluten which Dr gundry
loves to hate now when patients that
suffer from celiac disease eat gluten
the gluten leaks out of their gut and as
a result the body attacks it causing
inflammation and damage now obviously a
number of health influencers will
extrapolate this information to claim
that gluten will have this effect on
everyone and not just those with
Celiac's disease but what what is gluten
this is pretty sad because I don't know
and Dr gundry
tea by saying that it's not just gluten
it's all lectins in all forms
so we gotta remove them all P.S this is
just a sidebar but despite what Dr
gundry claims gluten is not even elected
like we find gluten in foods that
contain lectins like whole grain bread
but they're not the same components so
yeah just one of many confusions and
inaccuracies in this book but back to
his claims because the one that got
celebrities like Kelly Clarkson and
Usher was the promise of weight loss now
Dr gundry explains the link between
lectins and weight by suggesting that
lectins mimic insulin AKA what
influencers call the fat storage hormone
so by gundry's Logic when you eat
lectins you're increasing your body's
fat storage and ultimately your weight
where does he get the data to support
this claim well from a single study done
in 1980 on isolated fat cells from rats
in a Petri dish seems on brand but
anyway in the study high levels of
lectins reduced insulin sensitivity and
this led to higher levels of circulating
insulin which he concluded would cause
weight gain now besides the fact that
high insulin levels are not the cause of
weight gain check out my video on
insulin and weight gain right here you
can't just take animal studies like this
and apply the findings to living humans
in this study the rat's fat cells were
soaked in lectins in a Petri dish
there's no evidence that lectins
consumed in like beans can even get into
our fat cells not to mention how much
volume consumed would be needed to even
come close to the volume directly
applied to the rat's fat cell it's an
outrageous assertion based on again
nothing more than a far-fetched Theory
the more likely reason for celebrities
weight loss success on this diet is less
to do with lectin's insulin-like
properties and more to do with the fact
that you're just cutting a ton of food
out the plant Paradox diet includes a
three-day cleanse to start four to six
weeks of repair and restore and then a
maintenance phase where you reintroduce
some of the foods that you eliminated
before now the cleanse is really strict
removing all dairy grains or pseudo
grains fruit sugar seeds egg soy
Nightshade plants roots or tubers corn
soy canola or other inflammatory oils
with no mention of what these even
include along with any form of beef or
other farm animal meat basically you'll
be eating a handful of approved
vegetables small portions of wild caught
fish pasteurized chicken corn products
tempeh or hemp tofu as well as avocado
and a few approved oils now in the
repair and restore phase you can eat a
little more things but you're still
eating a very low carb low protein diet
and in the Final Phase you actually
reduce your protein even more 4. a very
strange progression alone that should be
a pretty big red flag Dr gundry's
recommendations of how much protein you
need seems to like flip-flop and change
throughout the book but in one paragraph
he says that He suggests people should
not have more than
.37 grams of protein per kilogram per
day to put this in perspective that's
less than half of the recommended
dietary allowance for protein which is
already considered like the bare bear
minimum and not necessarily the average
needed to thrive so to summarize this
dumpster fire of a diet from a weight
loss lens lectin isn't a secret culprit
of all the world's problems this dye is
just basic restriction with a
pseudoscience woo explanation to
legitimize it a lot of Wellness diets
today play on the psychology of
restriction by taking the explicit Focus
away from inches and pounds and onto
Health especially gut health but this is
just a pig with a new shade of lipstick
if it walks and quacks like a diet it's
a diet full stop stop tampering with the
smell so I think we've established that
the research to support a leptin free
life isn't great but let's consider it
from another angle could cutting these
Foods out do more harm than good surely
if us dietitians have gone it all wrong
and Dr gundry's right populations who
consume a lot of lectin-containing foods
would be morbidly obese and chronically
ill but again big shocker ahead when you
look at people who base their diets on
plant-based Foods including all of those
toxic beans and lentils as well as
Nightshade veggies like tomatoes and
eggplant you can see they're doing
pretty effing well this kind of diet is
typical for one of our major blue zones
the Mediterranean region which we have
evidence to suggest is one of the
healthiest diets for reducing the risk
of chronic disease so this feels like
another huge strike for the anti-electin
movement to me now before the comment
Warriors like get at me I need to share
that a lot of plant Paradox Defenders
will insist that Dr gundry doesn't
explicitly say you shouldn't eat legumes
they say you can have legumes if they're
cooked a certain way and this Nuance is
confusing because for like 90 of the
book he goes on about how dangerous
lectins are and how you need to get them
like the [ __ ] out of your life but to
not lose the vegan and vegetarian
consumers he makes the following
statement a pressure cooker will destroy
the lectins in beans and other legumes
which are a fantastic source of
non-vegetable protein as well as in
vegetables in The Nightshade and squash
families actually fruits better yet
pressure cooked beans shorn of their
offending lectins serve as a smorgasbord
for your gut buddies and can improve
longevity and enhance memory
uh what so all this time he's been going
on about how these exact foods are
basically killing us and all you needed
to do was cook them and all of a sudden
they're a smorgasbord for your gut
um
don't we all do this anyway like who was
eating raw beans who was eating dried
wheat berries as a snack it seems like
he needed a solid scary fear-mongering
hook to get people in and then needed to
like fill some pages to fulfill his book
contract but the book would have been
complete if he just wrote on page one
hey kids cook your beans I don't agree
with gundry on a lot of things but I do
agree with this we absolutely should not
be eating a lot of raw or active lectins
they can and do make people pretty sick
but the way these foods are consumed
almost exclusively drastically
inactivates the lectin levels lectins
are typically found on the outer surface
of foods and their water soluble
proteins so by soaking them or cooking
them using any kind of high heat
water-based method like boiling or
stewing you're going to inactivate about
94 to 99.8 percent of the lectin thereby
protecting yourself from any negative
side effects the same goes for canning
where the process uses high heat and
stores the legumes in water which
leeches even more lectins out do we have
to use a pressure cooker no of course
not it's just a faster more convenient
method of cooking most centenarians
living in the Mediterranean are not
using pressure cookers for their beans
and they are apparently doing just fine
letting containing foods like legumes
whole grains and nuts are consistently
associated with lower levels of heart
disease diabetes and weight gain they
contain a host of beneficial nutrients
like protein fiber healthy fats vitamins
and minerals all of which work
symbiotically to improve our health
cutting these out based on a theory that
doesn't even make sense in the context
of how humans eat is the epitome of
backwards thinking not only do the
benefits of these Foods outweigh their
potential risks but some research
actually suggests guests that lectins
have antioxidant properties so instead
of causing inflammation as Dr gundry
suggests they may actually help to
control it they also bind to some
carbohydrates and in doing so slow down
their digestion and absorption
potentially reducing blood sugar and
Insulin spikes some very early research
is even suggesting that lectins may even
help to support cancer cell death now
this is super preliminary research but
let's keep our finger on the pulse on
that because I think anything in the
cancer research world is worth staying
hopeful for so I want to close this off
by empathizing with those who have read
and followed this doctor's problematic
advice when you see an MD on the cover
of a diet book you rightfully should
expect the content to be legit but as
we've seen over the years from a number
of celebrity phds and MDS doctors are
not always the most credible sources for
nutrition information no disrespect
because I trust that this man is a
wonderful heart surgeon but unless they
seek it out in continuing education most
MDS are given very little formal
training on nutrition and we can't fault
them at that but I do expect better
interpretation of health research and
data and while most readers might see a
citation or an authoritative claim made
by a doctor and accepted as gospel I
hope my analysis has shown that not all
research is created equal the
recommendations of this diet are not
only largely based on mere Theory but
most of it doesn't even make theoretical
sense so bottom line eliminating lectins
from your diet is not going to magically
cure you of all that ails you as Dr
Grundy likes to say eating a balanced
diet that includes a wide range of
mostly minimally processed foods is a
far more sustainable and supportive
choice I hope my videos have helped you
think more critically about the
information that you see on online and
remember if it sounds too good to be
true even if it's coming from a doctor
unfortunately it probably is so on that
note that's all that I have for you guys
today if you liked it be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on what you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]